the interesting thing is the physical
scale is so much smaller so the
distances that you have to separate a
character from the background often tiny
so we used quite a lot of the theater
lights you know profile lanterns that
use in theaters have internal shuttles
like a projector which can give you very
very fine light beams and you can kind
of squeeze them into these gaps and if
you'll you'll see somebody's actually on
some of the things we'll show on Sunday
and we use very small versions of those
actually they were kind of made for shop
fittings really but these very very fine
profile lanterns which are very very
precise and that's the sort of thing you
have to have to get your head around
actually the models assets quite small
you're lighting it in the same way as
you'd like a full-size set but your
distance is your tolerance is so much
finer it takes a little bit of getting
getting used to happy it's always very
important way you put the camera as well
am we believe it's a real world I mean
yeah we treat it as a real world but
you've got to get the camera into there
and I level which in the early days was
quite difficult the size of the cameras
we were shooting on like 35 mil
Mitchell's their big cameras in fact if
you put flat on the set the lens would
be higher than the puppet so you have to
build the sets in the corn so you get
the camera down low a lot of times we'd
have to use as almost like a mirrored
arrangement is called a pentaprism there
where you have the camera tilt it down
looking at mirror so actually you can
get that low angle view point particular
for the train chase again has to keep it
down at their level so it's very
important m and avoiding high shots the
cameras should always be in a position
it would be in real life you can't just
look down on it I mean where's that from
you God or something I mean if you had a
looking down shot it would have to be
from a window ledge or you'd have see a
bit of building in front of it so they
look like you were looking over a
balcony or something and so very careful
placement of the camera always an action
from very early on I think as I did
quite a lot of theater lighting as a
student and I thought when we're doing
our early work why not put the same
amount of effort and thought into it as
if you would either live action all
you're doing a kind of theatre show it's
going to take a long time to animate the
scene so you made so spend a bit of time
actual getting the lighting looking
dramatic and to our mind it was in a
wheel making films they happen to be
animated it was
way around it wasn't like oh we're
making animated films hey can ball be
high key lighting it was we're going to
make films are going to be some of them
and some of the short films he made her
actually quite poignant and quite
dramatic they weren't Nestle comedy
films but they had a quite a bit yeah a
much more dramatic lighting style you
might have otherwise seen stop foreign
films of the day and I think you know
when you're watching movies that's what
you want both Dave and I you know
understanding the emotional impact of
light is is crucial to all filmmakers
and that's what we've always trying to
put into the movie to make